Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson is defending rioters in
Brazil and baselessly claiming that the Brazilian
election was, quote, rigged. I don't think this
will come as a shock to many of you. Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson, who has taken very
strange positions on Russia's invasion of Ukraine,
who has taken very strange positions on
everything from free speech to terrorism
over the years. You know, he says flat
out the election in Brazil was rigged.
And then he uses that to justify and defend the
rioting that we are seeing in the Trump riots,
Brazil version that we talked about yesterday.
Speaker 2: Let's listen to what was very clearly
a rigged election. A convicted criminal called
Lula da Silva is now the president of the most
important country in South America. Millions of
people in Brazil understand exactly what happened.
They know that their democracy has been hijacked,
possibly forever. But there's not much they can
do about that. Lula may be a criminal, in fact, he
is. But he has the full support of both the Biden
administration and the Chinese government.
Speaker 1: Well, he won.
That's an important detail. He won.
Speaker 2: So yesterday, in frustration,
a group of Brazilian protesters swarmed
their legislature. Watch thanks to what was.
Speaker 1: So then he then he shows
the video. Tucker Carlson then goes
on to say that what happened in Brazil is being
likened to January six, but that that is very
much not the case. Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: You may actually have seen some of that
video in the United States over the last couple
of days. And you saw it because it has political
uses. What's happened in Brazil is being likened
to January six. And of course, populist leaders
in this country are being blamed for it. Oh, it
was Trump and Steve Bannon who did it. That's not
true. But even if it were true, it would be just
the tail end of the story would be the result of
something that happened before. So the obvious
question is, why are protesters in Brazil so
angry? Right. Well, they're angry because the new
Lula government has eliminated their most basic
civil liberties. Lula is working to turn Brazil
into a Chinese style dictatorship, and he's doing
it very quickly with the maximum aggression. What?
No, immediate. Don't want to talk about that.
Speaker 1: Because it's not true.
Speaker 2: Fuzed to why? Well, for
reasons that should make you very nervous. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen, I'm. It's. It's incredible when
the right becomes so extreme and unhinged that
I end up doing the strangest things on the show.
And what I mean by that is I'm no fan of Lula
politically in the sense that, of course, if I was
in Brazil and my choices were Lula and Bolsonaro,
I vote Lula. But I've told you, Lula is in the
mold of this sort of populist rhetoric, kind of
corrupt in the vein of some other South American
leaders where he's better than Bolsonaro. But
it's not like I go, Wow, this is someone I really,
really think is a absolutely fantastic person.
But if I'm on the side of the rule of law, there
is no option here but to defend the legal basis
for Lula's win period, to defend the legal basis
for Lula being the president and to unanimously
and and categorically condemn what is happening
in Brazil and a similar attempt to what we saw in
the United States. Because at the end of the day,
Tucker says, well, it's different. It's different
in that the mass arrests of the rioters seem to
have started more quickly. That's that's good.
It's different in that it's happening after the
inauguration rather than before. That's true. It's
different in that the guy they're rioting on the
behalf of Bolsonaro is in Orlando, in a hospital
after going to KFC and a Publix. That's different
than what Trump was up to on the day of the Trump
riots. But it is the same in the sense that people
are destroying property and being violent and
trying to overwhelm police because they want a
candidate that lost to be the president. That's
the exact same thing. Brazil counted all of its
votes in ours, just the way MAGA wants the United
States to do. They did it in Brazil, but still
they say it was fraudulent. Brazil's military
found no fraud in the election. And then they say,
well, but they didn't rule out the fraud. Well,
what exactly do you mean by that? They didn't rule
it, but they didn't find any. Oh, no, no, no. But
that that that's that weird language. It is indeed
the same thing in terms of its motivations. And
at this point, should we even be surprised that
we are seeing Tucker defend the rioters? I say
no. We'll have these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram for
David Pakman show. And please make sure you
are subscribed to the YouTube channel at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.